はいほろよい食限定
ラムネサワーと
カップねーどるー
世界金かける
ガンプラです
もうこっちは別にいいよ好きですよ
あ
未成年の人はダメせお酒本当に僕に中ですから
飲んでいいんです問題はこっちですよ
ガンプラがついてるんですよ
カップラーメンにで値段もとプラベのくせに587いんじゃないかな
かなかな x 天使メガネ弾でした
あった
わっ
こういう
それを砂金を eyes of 9
もう1袋9だしてきたわけないですよ
それで3分が何でその間にも作っちゃいましょう
my light
意外と多いですやばいこれけっこうやばいですよ
できた八千年過ぎた頃からもっと恋しくなった
一億と二千年前の頃から智子著
パティの沿いそれでも今日はなんか
もう
もうもじゃないことはしません
若いのやっぱり若いです赤い本当にあたりですよ赤いとしか言いようがない赤い赤いん
です赤いんですかいいんです
あー思ったことから来ないですよ
飛び続けて辛いですとする僕なんだも全然詳しくないんですけど
きっと好きな人は好きなんでしょ
これはアレですよ
彗星の赤い車
アズなブルーですよね動かしてますの類のガンダムなんで
3ガンダム好きでん
かわいいのが好きな人
あとこれはな船サワーとこれはありませんけどおいしいのかやみつきになる辛さです
バイトが位で突かれているところにお酒を投入したら
こんな感じになります
じゃ
me